françois el bacha bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france alors
on le voyait un quotidien des libanais
devient toujours plus compliqué en
pleine pénurie le prix des carburants
encore augmenté hier pourquoi cette
augmentation à ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer
en fait il n'y a plus de réserves
monétaires disponible donc
automatiquement la banque du liban afin
de financer
les différents programmes de subventions
que ce soit aux carburants mais aussi
aux médicaments ce qui est un peu plus
grave quand même
ce cette fin aurait dû avoir lieu en
fait un dessin de janvier et par miracle
on a réussi à le faire poursuit jusqu'à
maintenant et le gouverneur de la banque
du liban il y à peu près trois semaines
un mois il s'était engagé le port
jusqu'à fin septembre mais on dirait
qu'il doit être la banque du liban des
problèmes de plus en plus critique au
niveau 2 de ses possibilités de
financement et donc elle a décidé
unilatéralement d'arrêter
d'accorder ces subventions maintenant il
ya aussi un objectif politique à cela
quels objectifs politiques
il y en a un bras de fer de plus en plus
important entre le gouverneur de la
banque du liban et les autorités
politiques
il y à l'audit juricomptable des comptes
la banque du liban on a le ministre on a
le ministère des finances pour lequel
rien
alors on va boire l'opération financière
de la banque du liban est renommé et on
change les législatifs de 2,2 de mai
2002 qui sont bientôt à l'horizon alors
on le comprend à une hausse qui a une
conséquence directe sur le quotidien des
libanais quel autre répercussion cette
hausse du prix des carburants on va
avoir sur l'économie libanaise mais en
général
déjà
obligatoirement une remontée de
l'inflation en fait c'est pas 66% de
semaine donc on a une hausse non pas 2
66% à 2 semaines on a une hausse de 100
93 % sur un an ce qui est énorme
ensuite on avait surtout des problèmes
de liquidités au liban donc ça va encore
renforcer la pression sur la monnaie
nationale et diminuer encore plus ce
pouvoir d'achat il faut savoir que le
salaire médian au liban est d'à peu près
de deux millions de livres libanaises
une et donc quand dix recettes les 1500
dollars avant la crise il ya deux ans
ses sandales c'est moins de 100 dollars
aujourd'hui
donc évidemment le pouvoir d'achat est
fortement affectée par cette hausse est
ce que avec cette situation on assiste à
de la contrebande à une économie
parallèle qui est en train de
s'organiser au liban
il ya toujours eu un phénomène de
contrebande au liban
on a eu déjà maintenant un marché noir
qui s'est installé sur le domaine des
carburants simplement parce qu'on avait
des pénuries on avait déjà un phénomène
de contrebande vers la syrie
mais maintenant la ce phénomène de
contrebande interne au liban
et on découvre à l'heure actuelle
d'importants stocks dans les stations
essence
dans des entrepôts on ne découvre 160
tonnes d'essence et de carburants
certaines des naissances et perdurant et
ainsi de suite même dans des dans des
stations essence en construction qui
sont fermés ces gens là ont acheté
davance des stocks importants en pensant
justement à la fin des subventions alors
dans ce contexte le hesbollah annoncé
l'importation de carburant iranien est
ce que cela pourrait aider le pays
quelles répercussions
il y aura bien sûr
des répercussions au niveau politique
déjà mon âme dans un bras de fer entre
les états unis et le hezbollah et on
voit déjà que aussi les états unis
parallèlement à l'annoncé du hezbollah
ont déjà réagi ils ont voulu ils ont
annoncé par dont le
un plant qu'ils à remettre en état un
oléoduc et un gazoduc arnaud qui
pourrait justement permettre au liban de
disposer de gaz pour ses centrales
électriques à oman drire la facture pour
la production d'électricité et mais ce
gazoduc qui passe par la syrie donc là
bas il ya il faudra négocier il faudra
qu'ils négocient quelque part avec la
syrie pour permettre le passage de ce
gaz égyptien
donc mais que la conversion des
centrales etc ça réclame du temps et le
hezbollah lui il a des solutions
immédiates a laissé deux tankers qui
devrait prochainement arriver au liban
et comment la communauté internationale
elle peut intervenir à doit intervenir
pour aider le liban que peuvent espérer
les libanais de la part de locke ou plus
précisément de la france mène
peut à la rigueur de lacq orthez des
lignes de crédit justement pour pouvoir
financer les achats de fioul à la place
de la banque centrale il faut absolument
pas passer par la banque centrale il
faut plutôt qu'on ait une sorte de
de monitoring entre quantités réellement
commandes et le fuel et l'essence de
carburant et de médicaments aussi
et quantités réellement acheminé au
liban parce qu'on a probablement des
détournements à ce niveau là
merci beaucoup françois el bacha pour
votre éclairage rappel vous êtes
économiste et fondateur de mise la news
[Musique]